Hi, this is Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. And this week I sat down with A. Savage, a musician and visual artist. His band, the Parquet Chords, is one of my favorites. They have a thoughtful kind of art rock uh insight into our culture that's sometimes acerbic sometimes humorous uh always very fun to listen to and he has very interesting uh visual art that kind of suggests movement emotion um fresh interesting and graphic uh we'll link to both of his websites for his projects and the show notes. But I hope you guys enjoy the interview, The Psychology of Music with Ace Savage.
大家好，我是Joel Blackstock，欢迎收听Taproot Therapy Collective播客。本周我邀请到了音乐家兼视觉艺术家A. Savage。他的乐队Parquet Courts是我最喜欢的乐队之一。他们对我们的文化有一种深思熟虑的艺术摇滚式的洞察，有时尖刻，有时幽默，而且听起来总是非常有趣。他还有非常有趣的视觉艺术，传达出一种动感、情感，既新鲜有趣又富有图形感。我们会在节目介绍中提供他两个项目的网站链接。希望大家喜欢这次关于“音乐心理学”的访谈，嘉宾是Ace Savage。
And we're enormously grateful that he sat down to talk with us. So without further ado, I'll go ahead and roll that interview. One of the reasons that we're having you on is to talk about kind of the relationship to trauma and creativity and just the creative process of the unconscious, but also just what people see into the mind of a creative that's successful. Because we work with a lot of younger people, a lot of people that like your music, a lot of people that just like creativity in general. I think being able to see what somebody's processes is so empowering, especially right now when everything is so atomized. Um, we started this,
我们非常感谢他能抽出时间与我们交谈。那么，废话不多说，我们直接进入访谈。我们邀请你来的原因之一，是想探讨创伤与创造力之间的关系，以及潜意识的创作过程，同时也想让大家深入了解一位成功的创作者的内心世界。因为我们接触了很多年轻人，很多喜欢你音乐的人，以及很多单纯热爱创造力的人。我认为能够看到别人的创作过程是非常有启发性的，尤其是在当下这个一切都如此原子化的时代。嗯，我们开始这个，
like we called it a social encounter group recently just because every clinician was hearing from everybody who was like, uh, you know, 20 to 30, like I don't want to go to church and I don't want to go to bars and I don't know anywhere else to meet people. And all my friends are on discord and it's either not healthy or it's, you know, limited. And how do I do that? And, you know, none of us had an answer. So, you know, we were like, okay, we're going to do this, this mixer.
就像我们最近称之为“社交邂逅小组”一样，因为每位临床医生都从20到30岁左右的人那里听到类似的话：“我不想去教堂，也不想去酒吧，我不知道还能去哪里结识朋友。我所有的朋友都在Discord上，要么是不健康的，要么是有限的。”我该怎么做呢？我们都没有答案。所以我们想，好吧，我们要举办这个聚会。
And then y'all are encouraged afterwards to go out to eat and, you know, whatever. It's not therapy. It's really just an opportunity to encounter, you know, the creative and spiritual and personal aspect of life that we never get a chance to anymore you know yeah I mean that is something that is kind of disappearing or rather becoming more online is is people meeting and like well it's I mean it's a way that's just kind of affected culture really. Whereas one point like people would have met, you know, and you mentioned you mentioned church, but you know,
之后鼓励大家一起出去吃饭，或者做点别的。这不是心理治疗，这只是一个机会，去邂逅生活中那些我们再也没有机会接触的创造性、精神性和个人层面的东西。是的，这确实是正在消失，或者说变得越来越线上化的东西，人们的相遇方式，这确实影响了文化。曾经人们会见面，你提到了教堂，但你知道，
like at, at a show or like at some sort of place where like-minded people go. For me, it was like, I met a lot of my friends like in the DIY scene around the US. But you know, it's important to keep that, it's important to keep the quality of that sort of interaction because ultimately that is I think something that cultivates creativity and just genuine connection in a way that online interaction, though it, you know, it
比如在演出中，或者在志同道合的人去的地方。对我来说，我是在美国的DIY场景中结识了很多朋友。但保持这种互动的质量很重要，因为我认为这最终是培养创造力和真诚联系的东西，而线上互动虽然有其优点，但确实无法做到。
does have its pros, just can't, you know. And that's something I've noticed is that things just kind of are part of culture and especially part of young people's culture is increasingly about being online which just doesn't it just doesn't provide the same thing well and it's interesting because i think that like you see kind of the boomers come up and a lot of their parents are you know coming from a harder economic situation than they had and they their parents kind of over provide for the boomers, you know, material support, but they don't give them a ton of emotional support.
它确实有优点，但就是无法……这是我注意到的，事情正成为文化的一部分，尤其是年轻人的文化，越来越多地关于在线上，但这并不能提供同样的东西。这很有趣，因为我认为你可以看到婴儿潮一代成长起来，他们的父母经历的经济状况比他们更艰难，所以父母在物质上过度补偿了婴儿潮一代，但并没有给他们太多的情感支持。
And of course, this is just broad strokes, not everyone's experiences like this. And so the boomers kids, the millennials are more like, they're really into authenticity and this kind of personal journey. And it gets silly at a certain point where you're like you know well this brewery is going to have the edison classic light bulb hung up on the cast iron pipe to be raw and authentic and you know we're going to turn everything into every you know part of life into this high type of art and um you know i mean there's it's good but there you know it gets silly as that kind of takes over.
当然，这只是粗略的概括，并非每个人的经历都如此。所以婴儿潮一代的孩子，即千禧一代，更看重真实性和这种个人旅程。在某种程度上这变得很傻，你会觉得，这家啤酒厂要在铸铁管上挂上爱迪生经典灯泡来显得原始和真实，我们要把生活的每一部分都变成这种高雅艺术，这很好，但当这种风气占据主导时，就变得很傻了。
And then the millennials kids, it's like they're they grow up with this therapy language almost where they, you know, it's not that it's bad to have that level of personal development and search for, you know, your authentic self online. But, you know, you're like, all right, guys, it's time to take the ACT. And they're like, no, I need I need my 17th adjective in front of my sexuality or my particular brand of communism and it's like no that's that's fine you know but also you need to touch grass like you know you've got 13 people in kazakhstan that share your your politics you know and real life is happening yeah and it is nice that they're able to find those people and have that, you know, awareness of who they are earlier in life. But also there's just so few skills that even like my generation took for granted, you know, that was. So you were talking about before we started recording the way that the kind of therapy that we do.
然后是千禧一代的孩子，他们几乎是在治疗语言中长大的。并不是说拥有那种程度的个人发展和在线上寻找真实自我是坏事。但你会觉得，好吧，伙计们，是时候参加ACT考试了。他们却说，不，我需要在我的性取向或我特定的共产主义品牌前加上第17个形容词。这没关系，但你也需要接触现实。你在哈萨克斯坦有13个和你政治观点相同的人，但现实生活正在发生。是的，他们能更早地找到那些人并意识到自己是谁，这很好。但也有很多像我这一代人认为理所当然的技能，他们却缺乏。所以，在我们开始录音之前，你谈到了我们所做的那种治疗。
Are you familiar? Kind of of do you have any kind of psychology background or have you been to therapy are you comfortable saying that if you have or i have but i you know the first time i ever went to therapy i was um i was 29 i was almost you know in my 30s so you know i went as an adult and it was not part of my culture growing up and it was I mean for most of my life it was something that I thought I would never need so you know I I came late to it so no I didn't grow up with the language of therapy like so I mean I know some people especially people that you know kind of grew up here in New York where I live and have lived for 13 years I know people who were born into therapy basically but that was not that
你熟悉吗？你有心理学背景吗？或者你接受过心理治疗吗？如果你愿意说的话，你对此感到自在吗？我有，但我第一次接受治疗是在29岁，快30岁了。所以我成年后才去，这在我成长的文化中并不常见。在我生命的大部分时间里，我以为我永远不需要它。所以我接触得比较晚，所以我不是在治疗语言中长大的。我知道有些人，特别是在我居住并生活了13年的纽约长大的人，他们基本上是生在治疗中的，但那完全不是我的经历。
was not my experience at all yeah it is interesting and New York is like one of the only places where psychoanalysis psychoanalysis like pure psychoanalysis is still kicking you know it's just kind of normal for people here to talk about their analysts like it's a what do you hear something yeah and you don't I mean pure psychoanalysis really anywhere else it's just gone but it is still kind of around there maybe cuz Anna Freud settles there and it kind of has a established what do you call pure psychoanalysis is that I mean I mean because even like I don't really know
是的，这很有趣。纽约是少数几个纯粹的精神分析仍然存在的地方之一。人们在这里谈论他们的分析师就像谈论……你懂的。在其他任何地方，纯粹的精神分析基本上都消失了，但它在那里依然存在，也许是因为安娜·弗洛伊德在那里定居，并建立了一种所谓的纯粹精神分析。因为我甚至不知道
how to classify the therapy that that I've had but is that just like talk therapy laying down in the chaise lounge while someone takes notes pretty much yes and it's interesting you mentioned that I mean there it's a big conversation but the field starts with you know Freud says there's an unconscious and what it is is it's full of sex and violence and with, you know, Freud says there's an unconscious and what it is, is it's full of sex and violence. And then he, you know, Freud has this, he's raised by his mom that you're brilliant, you're going to be great. And he says, but his dad is extremely passive. His dad would get like beaten up in the street by anti-Semites and Freud would have these like the fantasies that his
该如何归类我所接受的治疗，那只是谈话疗法吗？躺在躺椅上，有人做笔记？基本上是的。你提到的很有趣，这是一个很大的话题，但这个领域始于弗洛伊德，他说存在一个潜意识，它充满了性和暴力。然后他……弗洛伊德说存在一个潜意识，它充满了性和暴力。然后他……弗洛伊德是由他的母亲抚养长大的，母亲认为他很聪明，将来会很伟大。但他父亲非常被动。他父亲会在街上被反犹分子殴打，而弗洛伊德会有这种幻想，认为他的
dad was like Hannibal of Carthage and write about it like he needed to be dominant but he also couldn't assert himself in conflict there's this weird kind of thing where Freud put everybody up on this pedestal and it's like you're gonna be the bulwark that carries on my teaching and then they become a version of him that isn't good when they have their own ideas. And then he knocks them off and finds another one. And so Jung and Adler and Otto Rank and everyone, that happens. Jung, which I agree with a lot more, says, you know, the unconscious is not just sex and violence. Maybe that's what's in your shadow.
父亲是迦太基的汉尼拔，并写下这些。他需要占据主导地位，但他在冲突中又无法坚持自己。有一种奇怪的情况，弗洛伊德把每个人都捧上神坛，说你要成为继承我教义的堡垒，但当他们有了自己的想法时，他们就变成了他不喜欢的版本。然后他把他们拉下神坛，再找下一个。所以荣格、阿德勒、奥托·兰克，每个人都这样。荣格，我更认同他，他说潜意识不仅仅是性和暴力。也许那是你阴影中的东西。
But there's these evolutionary forces that are kind of older than us that are in the unconscious and the ego is sort of reacting to them but to really heal and integrate you have to crack the ego open and start to feel some of this stuff which gets taken a lot of directions and so they're the short history of the profession just real quick is you know Adler and Freud and you know adlers about relationships, but they're dealing with an unconscious like, what is it that's bigger than us that we're not even though I'm thinking about this one thing, I'm, I'm
但潜意识里还有一些比我们更古老的进化力量，自我是在对它们做出反应。但要真正治愈和整合，你必须打破自我，开始感受其中的一些东西。这被引向了很多方向。所以，这个职业的简短历史是：阿德勒和弗洛伊德，阿德勒关注关系，但他们处理的是一种潜意识，即有什么比我们更宏大的东西？即使我在思考这一件事，我其实也在
responding to a lot of forces beneath the surface. And when you have Reagan and Thatcher come in in the 80s, and healthcare is incredibly corporatized, and education is incredibly corporatized academics, then they corporatized academics then they say okay none of that's real and that's all coming like none of that is effective this is woo-woo we're not paying for energy patterns right the same time Beck is coming out with cognitive behavioral therapy which is a reaction to psychoanalysis and he's like what's the point in talking about why you smoke
回应表面之下的许多力量。当里根和撒切尔在80年代上台，医疗保健被极度企业化，教育和学术界也被极度企业化时，他们说这一切都不是真的，这都是无效的，这是伪科学，我们不会为能量模式买单。与此同时，贝克提出了认知行为疗法（CBT），这是对精神分析的一种反击。他说，谈论你为什么在沙发上抽了30年烟，你妈妈做了什么让你抽烟，有什么意义？唯一真实的是行为，所以我们只测量行为。行为改变了吗？有些治疗师说他们做认知行为疗法，但你了解他们后会发现他们做的不仅于此。但纯粹的CBT是……所以精神分析，你说的区别是什么？和心理动力学之类的？精神分析就是分析，没有体验，治疗师非常被动，你只是在分析
cigarettes what your mom did to make you smoke cigarettes on the couch for 30 years why you smoke cigarettes the only thing that's real is behavior so we're just gonna measure behavior did the behavior change and you know there's some therapists that say they do cognitive behavioral therapy but you you get to know them and they are doing more than that but I mean pure CBT is you know so psychoanalysis you're saying what's the difference in that and like 40 and psychodynamic whatever you know psychoanalysis is just analysis there's no experience the therapist is very minimal you were just analyzing
某人现在正在做什么。心理动力学弗洛伊德疗法，你可能扮演父母的角色，或者说，你与我的关系，可能就是你与他人的关系，这种模式在这里显现。所以当认知行为疗法出现时，我不喜欢它，因为我们处理的是创伤患者，它往往会造成二次创伤。因为你用CBT所做的只是转移焦虑。你说，好吧，你每天喝六瓶啤酒，为什么不每天喝三瓶啤酒，玩三局大富翁？好了，现在玩六局大富翁，喝零瓶啤酒，你治愈了。因为数字下降了。但你没有处理行为背后的东西。
what somebody's doing right now psychodynamic Freudian therapy you're maybe holding the role of the parent or you know saying well your relationship with me that's how maybe your relationship with other people are and this pattern pops up in here something so when behavioral cognitive therapy comes out you know I don't like it because we deal with trauma patients and it tends to retraumatize them because what you're doing with CBT is just moving anxiety around you're saying like okay well you drink six beers a day why don't you drink three beers a day and play three games of Monopoly okay now play six games of Monopoly drink no
是的，它在你的身体里哪里？它有多久了？我们不在乎你喝多少啤酒，当你没喝啤酒时你感觉如何？是的。所以那种利用情感、利用边缘系统和身体的创伤知情疗法正在回归。因为保险公司意识到，给伤口贴一辈子创可贴比治疗它要花更多的钱。但这个过程是混乱且宏大的。80年代和90年代对这个职业造成的损害非常深远。没有足够的人在做治愈创伤的工作。但如果你有一个患有解离性身份障碍（DID）的人，你开始进行认知干预，说“拍拍手，告诉焦虑停止，一日三餐，去教堂，
beers you're cured because the number went down right now you know the thing behind the behavior yeah it's like where is that in your body how old is that you know we don't care how much beer you're drinking what do you feel when you're not drinking beer yes you know okay and and so that trauma-informed stuff that is using emotion is using the support ofical brain and the body is coming back because, I mean, really, it's coming back because, you know, insurance is realizing that it costs more money to put a bandaid on something forever, you know, than to treat it. But that process is messy and big. And the damage that's done to the profession in the 80s and 90s is just really profound. There's not enough people doing the stuff that heals trauma. But if you have somebody who has a dissociative disorder, a DID, and you start doing cognitive interventions, and you're like, well, just clap your hands, tell the anxiety to stop, eat three meals a day, go to church,
这是健康生活的症状，锻炼”，而他们仍然在翻腾和感觉糟糕，你是在诱导他们觉得“是的，我可以做到”。是的，我要做这件事，我会感觉更好。然后他们没有做到，这就是系统的失败。我明白了，谢谢你的解释。是的，你对你在20多岁时接受的治疗有什么了解吗？不，不是20多岁，我29岁开始的。好的，但我指的是……我30多岁了，我现在36岁，所以我做了这么久。是的，它不是行为疗法，你不会那样称呼它。我确实通过我交谈的那个人学到了很多关于荣格和荣格原型的东西，所以我猜这会被认为是分析，
here's the symptoms of a healthy life, exercise, and they still are roiling and feeling terrible, you're psyching them up to be like, yeah, I can do this. Yeah, I'm going to do this thing, and I this thing I'm gonna feel better than they don't and you know that is a failure you know of the system I see okay thank you for that explainer yeah it's uh do you have any idea of kind of the therapy that you were in when you went to therapy in your 20s uh no not in my 20s i i started at 29. okay but i mean uh my 30s really i'm i'm 36 now so that's how long i've been doing it um yeah no it's it's it's not behavioral you wouldn't call it that um i i did learn i did learn a lot about yung and union archetypes uh through this person i talked to like so it is, I guess it would be considered analysis,
但我认为我发现最有帮助的是只是和某人交谈，他们只是一个观察者，一面镜子，说“这就是我听到的，这就是我听到你说的，我以前听你说过这个”。这对我来说很重要，因为这不是……长期以来我以为，好吧，我不需要治疗，我有这么多朋友可以交谈。但那不是真的，因为你的朋友会受到你们关系的影响。你知道，
but I think I found the most, what I found the most helpful is just talking to somebody and them being you know just an observer just a mirror saying this is what I this is what I hear this is what I'm hearing you say I've heard you say this before that's been that's been important to me because that's not something you know for a long time I thought okay well you know I don't need therapy I've got all these friends I can talk to but that's not really true because your friends are colored by your relationships. You know,
他们对你有自己的看法，因为他们和你关系亲密。而且，友谊中存在复杂性，你并不总是能说出你听到他们说的确切内容，为了关系，你并不总是指出他们所说或所做的模式。当然，即使是进行彻底分析所需的工作量，你的朋友爱你、关心你，但要求任何一群人去做真正做好这件事所需的工作量，是不公平的。虽然在纽约，人们总是互相进行精神分析，这是常态。
they have their own perspective on you because they know you intimately. And it's, you know, there are complications within friendships where you don't always say exactly what you're hearing them say, you know, and you don't always point out, maybe for the sake of the relationship, the patterns of what they're saying or doing, you know. Sure, and even, you know, the amount of work that it takes to do a thorough kind of analysis, it's, your friends are, you know, love you and care about you, but it's not really fair, you know, to ask any group of people to do just the amount of work needed, you know, to really do that well well. Though here in New York, people do psychoanalyze each other all the time, so that's a part of the course. Yeah.
所以你做了一些关于潜意识和荣格原型的工作。作为视觉艺术家或音乐家，这种语言对你有触动吗？完全有。我偶然发现了一本荣格写的书，叫《人及其象征》。他写了其中的两章，他的弟子写了其余的部分。这让我作为一名艺术家对他产生了兴趣，谈论视觉语言、视觉词汇和图像学，以及这如何被解读为我们自黎明以来一直在阐述的符号谱系的一部分。
So you did some work with the unconscious and union architects and things. Did that language speak to you as a visual artist or a musician? Totally. Totally. Totally, totally. And I actually, I came across a copy of a book that Jung wrote called Man and His Symbols. Yeah. He wrote two chapters of it and his disciples wrote the rest of it, that kind of what is what turned me on to him as an artist and talking about, well, visual language and visual lexicons and iconography and how that's, you know, a lot of that can be interpreted to be in this lineage of symbols that have been, that we've been articulating since the dawn of
你知道吗？我也发现这在语言方面也很有趣，因为在歌词和诗歌中，也有一种词汇，字面上说，我们使用的词就是符号。语言可以是符号，实际上很多时候我们是在写同样的东西。我们创作的歌曲、诗歌，甚至电影和艺术，都是用这些不同的符号来解决同样几个想法的方式。所以我发现荣格的这一点很有趣。是的，我认为乔姆斯基的学术研究认为我们使用的声音是任意的。
time, you know? And I also find that to be interesting with language as well, because in lyricism and poetry, there is also a lexicon, literally, words that we use that are symbols, you know. Language can be symbols and how really a lot of the times we're writing the same, the songs and the poems and you know even the movies and art that we make are kind of ways of addressing the same few ideas with these different symbols. So that I find interesting about Jung. Yeah, I mean, I think Chomsky's academic stuff kind of says that the sounds that we use are arbitrary.
那是变量，但语言树是存在的，所有语言的发展方式都一样。我们只是在区域上插入不同的声音，但语言树是存在的，所有语言的发展方式都一样，我们只是在区域上插入不同的声音。但语言确实有一种原型模式。是的，你把什么声音与什么词联系起来取决于文化，但它的完成方式是相当普遍的。我们无法改变这一点，即使我们想改变，我们谈论和思考它的方式。
That's the variable, but that there's kind of language trees all language develops the same. We're just plugging in different sounds regionally but that there's kind of language trees, all language develops the same, we're just plugging in different sounds, you know, regionally, but that there's just one kind of archetypal pattern to language, really. Right. And, you know, what a sound you associate with what word is, is up to the culture, but the way that it's done is pretty universal. And we can't change that, you know, even if we want to, the way that we talk and think
没错，这塑造了我们的整个心理和对世界的体验。你见过那个吗？多年前的一项研究，他们无法弄清楚为什么在石器时代的洞穴里，人们会去那些很难到达的地方，而且对住所之类的并没有什么帮助。结果发现是声音，你去那些区域，可以通过回声获得这种早期的石器时代迷幻体验。这很酷，我没听说过，那很酷。这些
about it. Right, that informs our entire psyche and experience of the world yeah have you ever seen that what is it the there was a study they did like years back about they couldn't figure out you know why in these like Stone Age caves people were going to these places that were really hard to get to and they weren't particularly helpful with like shelter or anything and it ended up to be sound that you go to those areas and you can have this kind of early Stone Age psychedelic experience through echoes you know that you're that's cool no I've not heard of that that's cool these
共鸣更强的地方，还有一些区域，假设是你制作了这些洞穴壁画，在不同的地方放火，让那头水牛看起来像是在奔跑。但这是一种宗教仪式体验，影子戏。那很酷。所以，这其中有些东西非常古老。社会性动物在有东西死亡时最吵闹。真正的社会性动物，当狮子幼崽死亡时，母亲会走出去向神咆哮，尽管这在实际上没有任何作用。所以这是一个很好的观点，第一种声音来自于这种对死亡的意识，或者某种深刻的情感。
places that are more resident you know and then there are some areas where the hypothesis is that you make these cave drawings and you put a fire in different places and it makes that Buffalo look like it's running or something but it you know that it was this kind of religious course yeah experience yeah shadow play yeah that's cool so yeah and you there's something about it that's pretty old you know the social animals are most vocal when something dies you know the real social animals when the lion cub dies the mom goes out and roars at god even though it's not practically going to do anything so there's a good idea you know that the first sound comes from this kind of awareness of death or some sort of deep emotional
关于狮子的灵性，抱歉，关于狮子是真的吗？是的，实际上所有的社会性动物都是这样，比如鲸鱼。如果你把鲸鱼放进水族馆，它会发出这种长长的发声呼唤。任何拥有纺锤状神经元、拥有哺乳动物那种关系大脑部分的动物都是这样。酷，有些动物实际上比我们拥有更多。鲸鱼拥有比人类更多的情感联结大脑部分。为它们感到高兴。是的，我希望……所以这很甜蜜和浪漫，但我们知道这一点的方式是，当你把它们关进海洋世界时，它们会表现出极度的悲伤，所以这也挺可悲的。
spirituality about lions i'm sorry is that true about lions yeah it's actually it's all social animals like whales if you take the whale and you put it in the aquarium you know it does these like long vocalizing calls anything with spindle neurons that has that mammalian like relationship part of the brain um cool some animals actually have more than we do whales have like a lot more of a the emotional bonding connection part of the brain than humans do good for them yeah yeah yeah i hope i so you know it it's it's sweet and romantic, but then the way that we know that is that they grieve extra bad
是的，那太可怕了。它们可能正在感受一些我们甚至不知道如何去感受的东西。那不是很糟糕吗？那么，你的乐队改变了一点，但我很好奇，你对什么流派感到自在？摇滚和吉他摇滚。但我很好奇，当我想到我在人生不同阶段把你归入的流派时，这是否更多地说明了你周围环境的变化，而不是流派本身的变化。
when you stick them in SeaWorld, so that's also kind of sad. Yeah, that's terrible. You know, they may be feeling something that we don't even know how to feel. Isn't that awful? Well, so, you know, your band has changed a little bit, but I'm wondering, you know, what genre are you comfortable with? One, you know, it's rock and guitar rock. But I'm wondering when I think about the genre I would have put you in at different points in life, if it says more about the environment changing around you than it does about the genre changing.
因为乐队确实改变了一点。如果我在高中，我会说，那是朋克，DIY朋克。如果我在高中后期，我会说那是独立摇滚。如果我在大学，我会说那什么都不是，那是大学摇滚。但其中有多少是Parquet Courts的改变，有多少只是我们思考流派和将事物归类的方式在变化？作为艺术家，我的工作不是给你定义我所做之事的语言，我不这么认为。
Because the band's changed a little bit. But, you know, if I was in high school, I'd be like, yeah, that's punk. That's DIY punk. And then if I was in late high school I'd be like oh that's indie and then if I was in college I'd be like that then he doesn't mean anything that's college rock you know but how much of that is the barquet courts changing and how much of that is just the way we think about genre and lump things together moving around as well really my job as the artist to give you the language to define what I'm doing, I don't think, anyway.
你知道，乐队在大多数情况下会改变，也应该改变，Parquet Courts自然也改变了。我并没有真正想过“哦，顺便说一下，我们现在是这种摇滚乐队了”。但如果非要说的话，我们制作摇滚乐，这就是全部，都属于那个范畴。如果有人想称它为别的什么，那也没关系。但艺术家的工作只是去创作它。有没有哪个流派你会觉得“不，那是错的”？如果有人称你为SoundCloud说唱歌手？
You know, yeah, bands in most cases change and ought to change, and, you know, naturally so has parquet courts I don't think about really oh by the way you know we're this type of rock and roll band now but I mean if you were to get down to it yeah I mean we make rock and roll and that's that's it all kind of follow falls under that umbrella and if someone wants to call it, you know, whatever the hell, then that's fine. But, you know, it's the artist's job just kind of to make it, really. Would there be a genre that you were just like, no, that's wrong? If somebody called you SoundCloud rapper?
我会在意吗？那是不对的，因为我们并不真正在SoundCloud上运作。而且，我认为任何称我们为那个的人，你都得质疑他们是否真的听过那个。因为那种混淆并不常发生。当然。所以，任何你自然被归入的流派，你都觉得没问题，你不会去想它，你只是在创作，那是次要的过程……或者说差不多吧。
I mean, do you care? I'd be wrong because we don't operate really on SoundCloud. And, you know, I think really anybody that called us rat, you'd have to question really if they'd ever heard rat before because that confusion doesn't happen often. Sure. But so there's any genre that you get lumped into naturally, you're fine with, you don't think about it, you're just creating, and that's the secondary process that's... or less yeah more or less and do you
当你做一些视觉艺术时，你获得过艾美奖，对吗？那是给电视节目的，所以我还没有在电视领域崭露头角。但你可能以为我因为《Human Performance》这张唱片的包装设计获得了格莱美提名。是的，那确实发生了。我为Parquet Courts做所有的艺术作品，专辑封面，显然，还有T恤设计和海报之类的。但除此之外，我也是一名视觉艺术家，这是我生活中巨大的
when you have like a could you do some visual art too you want an emmy is that right for the cover of something that you've done well it means they're giving out for television so i haven't i haven't really cut my teeth in tv yet but i I was, you're thinking that I was nominated for a Grammy for best like package design album art for the record, Human Performance. And so, yeah, that did happen. And I do all of the artwork for Parquet Courts, album artwork, obviously obviously but also like you know t-shirt designs and posters and stuff like that but aside from that I am also a visual artist and that's a huge
一部分，也是我花费大量时间做的事情。这也是我有时一半甚至更多收入的来源，通过我的绘画。所以我还有另一个与绘画有关的生活，很多人可能不知道。有些人专门作为画家关注我，显然我经常收到粉丝的联系，他们称赞我的艺术作品。很多时候他们指的是我为Parquet Courts做的东西，但我确实有作为视觉艺术家的另一面生活。
part of my life and that's you know that's that's that's what I spent a large amount of time doing and also that's how I make half sometimes more of my money is through my painting so I you know I have a whole other life that has to do with painting that maybe a lot of people don't know about there are people who kind of specifically follow me as a painter and then there there are you know obviously I get i get contact from fans a lot that they you know praise my artwork um a lot of times they're referring to like the stuff they see that i've done for parquet courts but there's you know i've got another life as a visual artist yeah well it's great stuff i mean and watching it kind of change with the music is
是的，那很棒。看着它随着音乐的变化而变化也很有趣。你觉得你在创作视觉艺术时是在进入同一个心理领域，还是觉得是不同的项目？嗯，这是一套不同的工具。这是一种不同类型的语言。一种是用声音和文字交流，而绘画……你是在传达一个信息，但这是一套不同的工具，你体验这些艺术类型的方式也不同。
interesting too i mean do you feel like you're going into the same psychic territory when you're making visual art or do you feel like different projects? Well, it's a different set of tools. It's a different type of language really. One is communicating with sound and words and painting is, I mean, you're communicating a message but it's a different set of tools and the way that you the way that you experience those types of art is different as well like
比如，一首歌你可能一次体验两到五分钟，你可能在看歌词，可能以不同的方式参与其中，但它有开始和结束，你用的是耳朵。绘画，画作就在那里，它没有开始和结束，它就在那里。所以你有不同的方式来获取信息。它不像歌曲或专辑那样基于时间。你用大脑的不同部分来观察它。
well for example a song maybe you're experiencing it for two to three to four to five minutes at a time you know maybe you're looking at the lyrics maybe you're engaging with it in different ways but it's got to start in an end and you're using your ears painting the paintings just there it doesn't start with an end it's just there and so you have a different way. And so you have a different way to take information in. And it's not time-based like a song or an album is. And you're using a different part of your brain to observe it.
同样，创作者用大脑的不同部分来创作它，使用完全不同的一套……这是听觉语言与视觉语言。所以它们相似，但也相当不同。当你创作这些东西时，你觉得你在咀嚼你自己的同一部分吗？你是在试图阐述不同的东西吗？你的创作过程是什么？都是我。这都来自我。我不知道我是否真的……我是一个不同的人，我想我是在试图
And as such, the creator is using different part of their brain to make it using a completely different set of, I mean, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's auditory language versus visual language, really. So they're similar, but they're also quite different. I mean, when you create those things, do you feel like you're chewing on the same part of you? You know, are you trying to kind of articulate a different thing? I mean, what's your creative process? It's all me. Yeah. I mean, yeah's it's all it's all me it all comes from me um I don't know if I've really uh I mean I'm a different yeah I guess I guess I'm trying
讲述不同的故事。当我绘画时，与我写歌时不同。我还没有太深入地思考过这个问题，以至于现在能以一种易于理解的方式向你阐述。但它们是不同的。它们与我结合的方式是专辑封面，那是它们交汇的时候，因为在几乎所有情况下，专辑封面都是基于音乐的，所以它深受音乐的影响。当你想到……我不知道，当我写小说时，我早年也做过一些超现实喜剧，有趣的部分之一是，我觉得如果我知道我在写什么，
to tell different stories um when I'm painting than I am when I'm songwriting, perhaps. I can't, I haven't thought about it too much in a way that I could really articulate in a digestible way to you right now. But I mean, it's Yeah, it's it's a different there. They are different, you know, I guess the way when the way that they're married to me is is the album art you know okay courts that's kind of when they come together because in pretty much all cases the album art is based on the music you know so it's informed heavily by the music well and when you think about like i don't know when i say i wrote some fiction i also did some like surreal comedy earlier in my life and like one of the parts that was interesting is like I felt like if I knew what I was writing
比如如果我试图表达“威权主义是坏的”，那这就是重点，那么我写的东西就不好了。但当我咀嚼一个我能感觉到但不知道是什么的想法时，我得到的艺术就更好。但这更难。有时几年后我回头看，会觉得“哦，原来我当时在说这个”，但我当时根本不知道。你是否有一个试图进入的地方？这很有趣，因为无论是音乐还是艺术，我首先喜欢知道我在谈论什么。
like if I was trying to be like authoritarianism is bad and that's the point then what I was writing wasn't good you know but when I was chewing on an idea that I felt but I didn't know what it was you know then the art I got was better but that's harder and then it would be like you know years later sometimes where I'd look at it and be like oh that's what I was saying but I didn't know what it was, you know, then the art I got was better, but that's harder. And then it would be like, you know, years later sometimes where I'd look at it and be like, Oh, that's what I was saying. But I had no idea really what, you know, do you, is there a place you try and go into, you know, that's interesting because with both music and art, I like to know what I'm talking about first.
这并不是说我知道我要表达的一切，或者说我在进入它时非常清晰，但我至少想知道我大致在试图说什么。我认为这是最难的部分，决定一首歌或一幅画大致是关于什么的。一旦有了这个，乐趣就开始了，因为那时你开始说，好吧，我该如何表达它？我可以用什么词？
Now that's not to say that I know everything I'm going to express or that I'm you know that I you know have the most you know that I'm so articulate going into it but I at least want to know more or less what I'm trying to say. That that's the hardest part, I think, is deciding what, broadly speaking, a song or a picture is about. Once you have that, then that's kind of where the fun part starts, because then you start to say, well, how can I express that? You know, what words can I use?
我可以用什么音符？我可以用什么调？什么颜色、形状？我该如何利用光？所以这变成了一种翻译行为。你所做的是你知道你在谈论什么，然后将其翻译成那种媒介。所以现在我非常投入于两者，我正在写一张新唱片。所以现在我有这些
What notes can I use? What keys can I use? What colors, shapes? How can I use light? And so it becomes an act of translation. What you're doing is you know what you're talking about, and then it's translating it into that media so right now I'm right now I'm really involved in both and and I'm writing a new record right now so so right now I'm I've got these
想法。以写歌为例，这实际上只是关于知道你在谈论什么，然后尽可能多地写它，找到其中最好的想法，然后继续前进，找到最好的词来表达这些想法、短语。你认为大多数音乐家都这样工作吗？或者你在意吗？这只是媒介，还是……我不知道，我有很多音乐家朋友，我并不真的和他们谈论过程，因为……我不知道，过程很有趣也很重要，但我不知道。
ideas and for songwriting for example really it's just kind of about knowing what you're talking about and then writing about it as much as you can and like finding the best ideas in there and then moving on from that and then finding the best words to express those ideas phrases you know what and do you think that most musicians work that way or do you care i mean is it just the medium or is that i don't know i don't know i don't i don't talk you know i've got a lot of friends who are musicians i don't talk about process with them really a lot because um i don't know uh that's i mean process is interesting and important but i don't know. That's, I mean, process is interesting and important, but I don't necessarily, I don't necessarily, when I hear a song, I don't necessarily think, I wonder, like, what steps they went through to write this. Unless it's bad, unless it's bad unless it's in visual art actually
过程很有趣也很重要，但我并不一定……当我听到一首歌时，我并不一定会想“我想知道他们经历了什么步骤才写出这个”。除非它很糟糕，除非它很糟糕，除非是在视觉艺术中。实际上，
um but uh you know my process that that's that's more or less what it is for me but also i don't really have a capital b process that i subscribe to and um that I use every time I'm gonna do something. Like it's always different. Sometimes, you know, a lot of times the lyrics come first. Sometimes they don't, sometimes melody comes first. And really for me, I mean, nothing really comes first. Most of the time they just are born separately
我的过程或多或少就是这样。但我并没有一个我所信奉的、每次做某事时都使用的“大写B”过程。它总是不同的。很多时候歌词先出来，有时不是，有时旋律先出来。对我来说，没有什么真正先出来。大多数时候它们是分开诞生的，
and are later part together and um I mean you did you come out of the Planet X record seeing it all like in the 90s early 2000s not at all no that I mean I remember it it you wouldn't have called it my thing at all really so when the when the earliest albums I mean was that all in new york what were what was going on with with you when you start the band you know over because it's been around a while um yeah we started in 2010 uh we were all living in new york the band started in new york uh i lived in denton texas uh before i lived in new york and I was in bands there. That Planet X scene, that was in Bloomington,
后来才拼凑在一起。你是在90年代末、2000年代初的Planet X唱片时期出来的吗？完全不是。我记得它，但你绝对不会称之为我的东西。所以最早的专辑，那是在纽约吗？当你开始组建乐队时，你身上发生了什么？因为它已经存在一段时间了。是的，我们2010年开始的，我们都住在纽约，乐队在纽约成立。我在搬到纽约之前住在德克萨斯州的丹顿，我在那里参加过乐队。那个Planet X场景是在布卢明顿，
Indiana. And they had a Texas foothold somewhere too, like Fort Worth and Bloomington was like the two. I don't know a ton about it. I knew friends that were involved in it. You know, I do know someone from Fort Worth who moved to Bloomington who was into it, but I mean, that kind of
印第安纳州。他们在德克萨斯州也有据点，比如沃斯堡和布卢明顿是两个。我对此了解不多。我认识参与其中的朋友。我确实认识一个从沃斯堡搬到布卢明顿并参与其中的人，但那种
scene was around, I that kind of scene was around I did kind of like that band this bike is a pipe bomb there from Florida but that I was I was more into like non folky punk I was going to like punk and so but I mean I in spirit it's cool cool, you know, but no, the band started having nothing to do with that, really, in New York in 2010. Well, it seems like y'all's album, I mean, the sound is, you know, it's changed over time, but it's still recognizable as the same band. But the albums are kind of chewing on pretty different things. I don't know. And that's my perspective.
场景确实存在。我确实喜欢那个叫This Bike Is A Pipe Bomb的乐队，他们来自佛罗里达，但我更喜欢非民谣朋克。我当时在听朋克，所以……精神上这很酷。但乐队的成立与那个完全无关，是在2010年的纽约。看起来你们的专辑，声音随着时间推移改变了，但仍然可以辨认出是同一个乐队。但这些专辑在咀嚼非常不同的东西。我不知道，这是我的视角。
I don't know what yours is but you know the second to last one there was kind of like a surreal you know anger or you know parody of something you know the most recent i hear more of like maybe acceptance or grief i mean i don't know what do you what are you going for? Oh, I mean, I don't know if I was necessarily thinking of either of those concepts with either of those records purely, but that doesn't mean that you're wrong because, you know, interpretation by the audience is really matters more than intent by the artists I think yeah and and I think maybe the only record that I can really truly say kind of has a theme or has like a thing that I wanted it to be about, well, maybe there's a few, but Sunbathing Animal comes to mind of being a record that's kind of about this duality of freedom and confinement.
我不知道你的视角是什么，但倒数第二张有一种超现实的愤怒，或者说某种模仿。最近的一张，我听到了更多接受或悲伤。我不知道，你在追求什么？哦，我不知道我在创作那些唱片时是否纯粹在考虑这两个概念中的任何一个，但这并不意味着你是错的，因为我认为观众的解读比艺术家的意图更重要。我认为唯一一张我能真正说有主题或有我想表达的东西的唱片，也许有几张，但《Sunbathing Animal》让我想起是一张关于自由与禁锢二元性的唱片。
And I think if any of the records about grief, it's probably human performance but you know to me there's a lot of anger in the record wide awake which is I think the one that you're talking about being yeah that's it's almost you know not parodying things but just a complete you know there's a willingness to use humor and anger simultaneously well that you have to really, I mean, in order to keep from going insane as an American and that record was recorded in 2017, a time that truly seemed insane.
如果说哪张唱片是关于悲伤的，那可能是《Human Performance》。但对我来说，《Wide Awake》这张唱片里有很多愤怒，我想这就是你提到的那张。它几乎不是在模仿事物，而是一种完全的……有一种同时使用幽默和愤怒的意愿。作为美国人，为了不发疯，你必须这样做。那张唱片是在2017年录制的，那是一个看起来确实疯狂的时代。
And so, I mean, there are angry bits of that record too, but I also think it's kind of joyful as well. Yeah. And I would say the same about um all of them really because anger is definitely a a thing that i think at least on a like subconscious level has to be somewhat there in rock and roll um and uh because that's what separates it from you know the rest really and but but but joy doesn't have to be there but it does just kind of it does just kind of give some depth and context to things and i don't know helps the medicine go down so to speak and i i guess when i was saying that wide awake sounded angrier like it seems like
所以，我的意思是，那张唱片里也有愤怒的成分，但我同时也觉得它有一种快乐。是的。对于他们所有的作品，我真的都会这么说，因为愤怒绝对是摇滚乐中不可或缺的一部分，至少在潜意识层面是这样，因为这就是它与众不同的地方。虽然快乐不一定非得存在，但它确实为事物增添了一些深度和背景，也可以说是让良药更易入口。我想，当我提到《Wide Awake》听起来更愤怒时，似乎
the last two albums are kind of chewing on the same thing but there's more of a acceptance you know it's a little calmer you know uh wide awake is is more kind of in your face uh perhaps that's perhaps perhaps like uh maybe risk maybe acceptance isn't the right word maybe resignation is the better word which is an act that we've all kind of done as americans in the past few years i think well yeah and they they both seem like they're dealing with just exhaustion about that there's too much that it's kind of endless that there's uh just this kind of uh i don't know there's a lot of like listing a lot of categories breaking them down you know almost kind of trying to tire out the i don't know i mean it's it's hard because
最后两张专辑探讨的是同样的东西，但多了一份接受，你知道，稍微平静了一些。嗯，《Wide Awake》更直接一些，也许，也许“接受”这个词不太准确，或许“顺从”更贴切，这是我们作为美国人在过去几年里都经历过的一种行为。我想，是的，它们似乎都在处理那种疲惫感，觉得事情太多了，没完没了，而且有很多像是在列举各种类别，把它们拆解开来，你知道，几乎是在试图让自己感到疲惫，我不知道，这很难，因为
you're mixing metaphor when you're trying to talk about music and like what you feel versus you know what's actually there in the lyrics or whatever but um i mean i do hear a lot of that um just this exhaustion with the complexity and the quantity of i think that that exhaustion could be considered a recurring theme in parquet courts for sure since since the beginning so i mean the when I think about like punk rock and anger angry music you know there's kind of there's a cathartic anger of just I'm gonna get up and scream and it feels good that you get sometimes and then there's like a more kind of mindful anger of like which I was associated with the more mature punk records that was like, this is bad. I'm going to articulate the problem with the system, you know? And, and I think that's why you're like with punk, you got more,
当你试图谈论音乐，谈论你的感受与歌词中实际存在的内容之间的区别时，你是在混用隐喻。但我确实听出了很多那种对复杂性和数量的疲惫感。我认为这种疲惫感肯定可以被视为 Parquet Courts 乐队从一开始就反复出现的主题。所以，当我想到朋克摇滚和愤怒的音乐时，你知道，有一种宣泄式的愤怒，就是“我要站起来尖叫，这感觉很好”，有时你会得到这种感觉；然后还有一种更具思考性的愤怒，我把它与更成熟的朋克唱片联系在一起，就像是“这很糟糕，我要阐明这个体制的问题”。我想这就是为什么你觉得朋克，你得到了更多，
it was almost more ethical where there would be like, you know, the bands were associated with the nonprofit that served food or protested the art core or, you know, the thrift store or something. But there was a relationship between the music and the lifestyle that was not just aesthetic like some genres and so i mean it sounds like you your albums are articulating a problem in a mindful way that you are angry about but you're not just getting up and screaming into the microphone because you it feels nice you know um i am doing that but i'm not just doing that i guess um and you know? But I don't know, maybe not. I am doing that, but I'm not just doing that, I guess. And, you know, part of songwriting for me is about,
它几乎更具道德感，比如，你知道，乐队与提供食物的非营利组织、抗议艺术核心、或者旧货店之类的东西有关联。音乐和生活方式之间存在一种关系，而不仅仅是像某些流派那样仅仅是审美上的。所以，听起来你的专辑是以一种深思熟虑的方式阐明了一个你感到愤怒的问题，但你不仅仅是站起来对着麦克风尖叫，因为那样感觉很好，你知道……我确实在那样做，但我不仅仅是在做那个，我想……你知道吗？但我不知道，也许不是。我确实在那样做，但我不仅仅是在做那个，我想。而且，你知道，对我来说，创作歌曲的一部分是关于，
yeah, like it is a form of therapy for me cause it is about processing things. And, I mean, I am using my voice and I'm using the way I use my voice. Let me say that again. I'm using my voice and I'm in a way where I can express anger through like volume and shouting. But I'm also using my words, too. So I'm doing both actually but yeah I mean I find that songwriting
是的，它对我来说是一种治疗形式，因为它关乎处理各种事情。而且，我的意思是，我正在使用我的声音，并且在使用我运用声音的方式。让我再说一遍。我正在使用我的声音，并且以一种可以通过音量和喊叫来表达愤怒的方式。但我也在使用我的文字。所以实际上我两者都在做，但是的，我发现创作歌曲
especially writing lyrics is kind of a way to process through one's thoughts and you know I'm not like providing solutions for anybody like it it's I'm just like I'm just as you know confused and in some cases angry as anyone else's it's just me going through it and and that's you know if that's that that can be something that other people can last on latch on to because they can identify with it you know well and it seems like i mean it kind of flares up and then calms down but i can't really think of a lot of bands that have been around 10 years that are doing guitar rock and big like it seems like i mean maybe it's the democratization of everybody can go out and buy a soundboard and
尤其是写歌词，是一种梳理思绪的方式。你知道，我并不是在为任何人提供解决方案，我只是像其他人一样困惑，在某些情况下也一样愤怒。这只是我经历的过程，如果这能成为其他人可以抓住的东西，因为他们能产生共鸣，那也很好。嗯，看起来，我的意思是，它会爆发然后平静下来，但我真的想不出有多少乐队存在了10年还在做吉他摇滚，而且规模很大。看起来，我的意思是，也许是因为民主化，每个人都可以出去买一个音响设备，
copy and paste loops and stuff um if they want to make music but i mean you guys, maybe it's the democratization of everybody can go out and buy a soundboard and copy and paste loops and stuff if they want to make music. But I mean, you guys, I mean, it's like y'all, Modest Mouse. I mean, there's a couple bands that have been around a while, but Guitar Rock just seems like it's been kind of on a slow decline for a while, you know, with resurgences here and there. Do you think that's just that it's harder? Or what do you notice, you know, when you're more in the mainstream or less in the mainstream even though you're doing the same thing well I mean I I really what I think it is I don't I don't know it is maybe it has been de-emphasized in our culture writ large, rock and roll, I guess. But I also kind of think that there are probably more bands than ever, but they're just not, you know,
如果他们想做音乐，就可以复制粘贴循环之类的东西。但我的意思是，你们，也许是因为民主化，每个人都可以出去买一个音响设备，如果他们想做音乐，就可以复制粘贴循环之类的东西。但我的意思是，你们，我的意思是，就像你们，Modest Mouse。我的意思是，有几支乐队已经存在一段时间了，但吉他摇滚似乎已经缓慢衰落了一段时间，你知道，偶尔会有复苏。你认为这只是因为更难了吗？或者当你更多地处于主流或较少处于主流时，即使你在做同样的事情，你注意到了什么？嗯，我的意思是，我真的认为它是……我不知道，也许它在我们的文化中被淡化了，摇滚乐，我想。但我同时也认为，可能现在的乐队比以往任何时候都多，只是它们没有，你知道，
it's just not at the central focus of culture the way it was, you know. But, I mean, if you go on a app like Bandcamp for example or SoundCloud like there's all sorts of bands out there like they're all over the place we don't like it's it doesn't it doesn't occupy the same niche in our culture that it once did say I don't know and you in the 90s, which in my lifetime, kind of the peak of alternative rock music on the radio, alternative rock music at the central focus of culture, which I think because of that, we're still tethered to it
它只是不像以前那样处于文化的中心焦点。但是，我的意思是，如果你去 Bandcamp 或 SoundCloud 这样的应用程序，你会发现各种各样的乐队，它们无处不在。我们不喜欢……它在我们的文化中不再占据它曾经占据的那个位置，比如，我不知道，你在90年代，那是我生命中电台另类摇滚音乐的巅峰时期，另类摇滚音乐处于文化的中心焦点，我认为正因为如此，我们仍然被它束缚着，
and constantly comparing the state of rock and roll to that moment. And if you compare it to that moment then yeah sure uh there are not there are not radio stations beyond college stations that are playing new rock bands and increasingly fewer radio stations most places also. Sure, yeah. And there's, so the way that you find new rock music is different than it was in the 90s. It's, you know, you have to, you have to like find new ways to seek it out.
并不断地将摇滚乐的现状与那个时刻进行比较。如果你把它与那个时刻相比，那么是的，当然，除了大学电台之外，没有电台在播放新的摇滚乐队，而且大多数地方的电台也越来越少。当然，是的。所以，你发现新摇滚音乐的方式与90年代不同了。你知道，你必须，你必须找到新的方式去寻找它。
For some people that's like band camp, but really, I mean, I think kind of the best way is becoming involved in a scene in a community of bands that are playing together and that's that's that's still there and it's uh i mean it i think with the pandemic put that on pause for a lot of people but um that will still it will still continue to be a thing i think think. I mean, there are a lot of young bands that are popping up and there's scenes like there's like the scene in London right now, specifically like South London
对一些人来说是 Bandcamp，但真的，我的意思是，我认为最好的方式是参与到一个乐队社区中，大家一起演奏，这仍然存在，而且它……我的意思是，我认为疫情让很多人暂停了这一点，但是……那仍然会继续存在，我想。我的意思是，有很多年轻乐队正在涌现，而且有像伦敦现在这样的场景，特别是南伦敦，
where there's all these kind of new rock bands coming out of and people are getting really into it young kids are getting really into it so you know it's just different really it's music the way that we kind of value music and the way that music
那里涌现出了所有这些新的摇滚乐队，人们真的对此很感兴趣，年轻人对此很感兴趣，所以你知道，这真的只是不同了。音乐，我们重视音乐的方式，以及音乐
is applied to our culture is just vastly different than it was 25 years ago well and the point where you're talking about that, you know, that rock was such a big cultural force, how much of that do you think had to do with it being a threat? You know, that it looked that was kind of the scariest thing that was the threat to the mainstream or whatever at that point.
应用到我们文化中的方式，与25年前相比已经大不相同了。嗯，在你谈到这一点时，你知道，摇滚乐曾经是一种如此巨大的文化力量，你认为这在多大程度上与它是一种威胁有关？你知道，它看起来是当时最可怕的东西，是对主流或什么的威胁。
And then it moved on to, well, now we're more scared of these other things. I mean, it seems like culture and politics like to platform something to attack and that a lot of American culture has that kind of dualism. You know what? How much of it was that at that point? And in culture, the scariest thing out there for my kids to like was this cool guy with a guitar. He looks like this. I don't know if it was. I mean, I don't know if it was that kind of threat. Like maybe the last time I remember a threat of that level, as far as in rock music in American culture would be like, I don't know, Marilyn Manson in the late 90s or something.
然后它继续发展，好吧，现在我们更害怕其他事情了。我的意思是，文化和政治似乎喜欢把某种东西推上台面进行攻击，而且很多美国文化都有那种二元论。你知道吗？在那个时候，这在多大程度上是那样的？在文化中，我孩子们觉得最可怕的东西就是这个拿着吉他的酷家伙。他看起来像这样。我不知道是不是。我的意思是，我不知道它是否是那种威胁。就像也许我记得最后一次那种程度的威胁，就美国文化中的摇滚乐而言，可能是90年代末的玛丽莲·曼森之类的。
But I think really what it was is like alternative rock kind of leech reached its logical conclusion when it became mainstream like when bands on the college rock scene started to become mainstream like you know like REM Rollins band, Nirvana, become these sort of mainstream things, then it's got to kind of reset, you know, and been a few moments a few examples parquet courts perhaps being one of them although we've never had the sort of like mainstream success that those fans i mentioned have where people go back in and they they're they're interested in it and then you know a few bands come out but also just like you know the the the way that new bands uh like i said get put out there is just different i i don't I don't really know I don't really know if it has some so much to do with being scary or not I just
但我认为真正的情况是，另类摇滚在成为主流时达到了它的逻辑终点。当大学摇滚场景中的乐队开始成为主流时，比如 REM、Rollins Band、Nirvana，成为这些主流事物，那么它就必须重置，你知道，并且有过几次时刻，几个例子，Parquet Courts 也许是其中之一，尽管我们从未像我提到的那些乐队那样获得过那种主流成功，人们会回去，他们对它感兴趣，然后你知道，几支乐队出现了，但也只是像，你知道，我所说的新乐队被推出来的方式就是不同。我真的不知道，我真的不知道这是否与是否可怕有太大关系，我只是
don't know if that's been the aim besides like metal I don't know I don't necessarily mean scary like it's like you know gonna tear down society but it's and I also don't want to say edgy you know but there's something that you know was different was new was titillating you know at one point and then that goes away it comes back you know and different yeah and that's I mean that's that's still happening like you know a lot of this music that they that people are calling like hyper pop right I think I think is kind of unnerving and scary and um and like alien in a way that rock and roll sort of used to be I mean let's be honest it is really truly hard to shock people now
不知道这是否一直是目标，除了金属乐。我不知道，我并不一定是指可怕，就像你知道，要摧毁社会，但我也不想说前卫，你知道，但有些东西，你知道，是不同的，是新的，是令人兴奋的，你知道，在某个时刻，然后它消失了，又回来了，你知道，而且不同。是的，我的意思是，这仍然在发生，就像你知道，人们称之为“超流行”（hyper pop）的很多音乐，我想，我认为它有点让人不安和害怕，而且……以一种摇滚乐曾经拥有的那种异类感。我的意思是，老实说，现在要震惊人们真的很难。
um and we're able to shock people in art um it's you've you've you've accomplished something I think a lot of that music like the hyper pop kind of stuff I don't dig it's not my thing at all but I can recognize that it is sort of fulfilling that function of being somewhat shocking and not sounding like anything that came before it which is you know you know, we can all, we should all hope for that, I think, as artists as you're trying to do something, even if you're working in rock and roll, which is this very kind of referential
嗯，我们能够在艺术中震惊人们……你已经完成了某件事。我想很多那种音乐，像超流行之类的东西，我不喜欢，它根本不是我的菜，但我可以承认它确实在发挥那种令人震惊的功能，而且听起来不像以前的任何东西，这是，你知道，我们都可以，我们都应该希望那样，我想，作为艺术家，当你试图做某事时，即使你在摇滚乐中工作，这是一种非常……参考性的、
kind of codified language, being able to do something that is new to people's ears. It's such a rare thrill. And do you have anything that is coming out? You want to promote anything that is coming up? Not really. I'm working on a solo record right now, but I can't really promote it in any way other than to say that I'm working on it. No, actually at the moment, no, not really.
编纂好的语言，能够做一些对人们耳朵来说是新的事情。这是一种罕见的快感。你有什么要发布的作品吗？你想宣传什么即将到来的事情吗？没有，真的。我正在制作一张个人唱片，但我无法以任何方式宣传它，只能说我正在制作它。不，实际上目前没有，真的没有。
You've caught me. People want to see visual art. Can they go somewhere to see that? You know, I haven't updated my website in a long time, but I do have one. It's a dash savage.com. Maybe this will be the, maybe this will be the motivating factor to me updating it.
你抓到我了。人们想看视觉艺术。他们可以去哪里看吗？你知道，我很久没有更新我的网站了，但我确实有一个。是 a-savage.com。也许这将是，也许这将是我更新它的动力。
I'm by and large, pretty bad at the internet and promoting myself on it. Well, it's kind of the exhausting part. I think to the creative is the marketing and making in detail stuff. It's never what you want to do. It's always been a struggle for me. That's why I'm grateful with Parkhead Chords
我总的来说，不太擅长互联网和在上面宣传自己。嗯，这确实是令人筋疲力尽的部分。我认为对创作者来说，营销和制作细节的东西。这从来都不是你想做的。这对我来说一直是一种挣扎。这就是为什么我很感激 Parquet Courts
that we have a record label that does all that kind of stuff for us. Well, the visual art is neat. I mean, there's just not a ton like that. And it is gallery art. But well, is there anything else that kind of jumps out? I don't want to be respectful of your time, but I really appreciate you talking.
我们有一个唱片公司为我们做所有这些事情。嗯，视觉艺术很棒。我的意思是，没有太多那样的东西。而且它是画廊艺术。但是，嗯，还有什么其他突出的东西吗？我不想占用你太多时间，但我真的很感谢你的交谈。
And I think that people will really enjoy having to hear what you have to say. Yeah, I mean, I guess all I would say is that, if anybody is listening that maybe hasn't tried an art form writing making visual art making music as a means to you know kind of deal with whatever they're going through mental health or whatever you want to call it if you haven't tried it give it a whirl you know start writing your thoughts down.
而且我认为人们会非常喜欢听到你要说的话。是的，我的意思是，我想我要说的是，如果有人在听，可能还没有尝试过一种艺术形式——写作、制作视觉艺术、制作音乐——作为一种处理他们正在经历的事情、心理健康或任何你想称呼它的方式，如果你还没有尝试过，试一试吧，你知道，开始写下你的想法。
Start thinking how you can translate those thoughts into an art form, into something, because it is an important part and has been for a long time of my life of getting things out, even if it is just screaming into a microphone. But maybe try that and then try screaming
开始思考如何将这些想法转化为一种艺术形式，转化为某种东西，因为它是我生活中很长一段时间以来释放事物的重要部分，即使只是对着麦克风尖叫。但也许试试那个，然后尝试尖叫
some feelings into a microphone. You know, I would say if you haven't tried something and you've wanted to for a while, go for it. Do you see places
一些感受对着麦克风。你知道，我会说，如果你还没有尝试过某件事，而且你已经想尝试一段时间了，那就去做吧。你看到过
where your creativity's helped you work through stuff but in i mean do you think about it that way or is that not really the way that you work well yeah i i i do think about it that way um i mean i think it's a cons i think i'm constantly working through things with with creativity there's not like a you know there's not re there's never been like a well you know, there's not really, there's never been like a, well, you know, I've written a bunch of songs about that now and I'm, I'm processed that and I'm done with it. It's always just, it's, it's always helping.
你的创造力帮助你解决问题的地方吗？我的意思是，你从那个角度思考它吗？还是那不是你工作的方式？嗯，是的，我确实从那个角度思考它。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这是一种持续的……我认为我一直在用创造力解决问题。从来没有像，你知道，从来没有过那种“好吧，你知道，我已经写了一堆关于那个的歌，我已经处理好了，我完成了”。它总是，它总是很有帮助。
And so that's kind of why I'm always doing it. There's, there's never a time where there's not something I'm working on, some type of art that I'm working on well that's that's helpful have you ever have you heard of brain spotting no so it's a it's an eye movement therapy it's newer than EMDR I think it works a little bit better I'm trained in both of them but it's it's fun I'm kind of wild I mean we use it a lot to lose creativity for creatives, but even in people that are just using it to treat trauma. There's like a creative explosion afterward I've been like every kind of therapy that exists I got not that exists But I've been in five or six different kinds of therapy with different therapists got different things out of each of the styles and really
所以这就是为什么我一直在做它。从来没有我不工作的时候，没有我正在创作的某种艺术。嗯，那很有帮助。你听说过“脑点疗法”（brain spotting）吗？没有。所以它是一种眼动疗法，比 EMDR 更新，我想它效果稍微好一点。我受过这两种训练，但它很有趣。我有点疯狂，我的意思是，我们经常用它来为创作者释放创造力，即使是在那些只是用它来治疗创伤的人身上。之后会有创造力的爆发。我尝试过现存的每一种疗法，不是说现存的，但我尝试过五六种不同类型的疗法，有不同的治疗师，从每种风格中得到了不同的东西，而且真的
You know enjoyed it but With brain spotting and we pivoted our whole clinic to this new brain-based medicine and somatic stuff because i just i was expecting nothing it was during covet it was online i didn't think this would work i was going to be looking at a pointer um i thought i'd get something out of it and be able to use it for whatever and then i just dissociated for 20 minutes it was like very psychedelic and what is it you i mean long so long story short you know all the theories about how this stuff works or theories but the subcortical brain where trauma
你知道，很享受它。但是有了脑点疗法，我们将整个诊所转向了这种新的基于大脑的医学和躯体疗法，因为我只是……我没抱什么期望，那是在新冠期间，是在线的，我不认为这会奏效，我以为我会盯着一个指针看……我以为我会从中得到一些东西，并能用它做任何事情，然后我就解离了20分钟，感觉非常迷幻。它是什么，我的意思是，长话短说，你知道所有关于这些东西如何工作的理论都是理论，但皮层下大脑，创伤
is stored but also are into it you know that intuitive creative gut reflex comes from it's very somatic and deep in the body come underneath language and cognition it's before you're thinking in language you're feeling mm-hmm so the the body kind of remembers one when I'm around people that make me feel threatened my heart it's a black hole or my stomach is hot or my skin ting you know there's all this stuff that's kind of stuck and until you get it out you're reliving it but your body also kind of remembers the position your eye was looking in during a traumatic event or like there's different associations like where do you look you know under your desk as a kid because you don't think you
被储存的地方，也是我们直觉的、创造性的本能反应来源的地方，它是非常躯体的，深植于身体中，在语言和认知之下。在你用语言思考之前，你在感受。嗯哼。所以身体会记住，当我周围的人让我感到受威胁时，我的心脏，它是一个黑洞，或者我的胃很热，或者我的皮肤刺痛，你知道，所有这些东西都卡住了，直到你把它释放出来，你都在重温它。但你的身体也记住了你在创伤事件中眼睛注视的位置，或者有不同的联想，比如你小时候因为觉得你
can learn math or whatever then that kind of gets wired in with this feeling see the therapist just has a pointer and they're looking for a certain pattern of dilation in the eye and when they find it you just kind of lose time sometimes uh you feel real strong physical um sometimes emotional but usually in the room just physical physical reaction okay and then over the next couple of days because the processing is mainly outside of the room there's just uh really strong emotional feelings that are younger you know i mean for me it was like i just felt very vulnerable and it didn't justify my surrounding like i didn't know why. And I mean, you're going through something that's bad
学不会数学之类的而看向桌子下面，然后那种感觉就和这种感觉连接在一起了。所以治疗师只是有一个指针，他们在寻找眼睛中某种扩张模式，当他们找到它时，你有时会失去时间，嗯，你会感到非常强烈的身体……有时是情感上的，但通常在房间里只是身体上的反应。好的，然后在接下来的几天里，因为处理过程主要是在房间外进行的，会有非常强烈的情感感受，比较年轻，你知道，我的意思是，对我来说，我只是感到非常脆弱，而且这并不符合我周围的环境，我不知道为什么。我的意思是，你正在经历一些糟糕的事情，
but it's so involuntary and unconscious that it's wild. It is interesting, even though it's kind of unpleasant. And usually afterwards there's this creative explosion. You know, a lot of people who they were just coming into process, you know, you combat or some domestic abuse or whatever. They're like, I can't quit drawing houses. Like I'm sitting in in meetings i'm drawing a house or i'm writing a point you know like something on so it's interesting and you're only out 40 minutes if if you uh you know some therapy
但它是如此不由自主和无意识，这太疯狂了。这很有趣，尽管它有点不愉快。通常之后会有这种创造力的爆发。你知道，很多人他们只是进来处理，你知道，战斗或某种家庭虐待之类的。他们说，我无法停止画房子。就像我坐在会议中，我在画房子，或者我在写诗，你知道，类似的东西。所以这很有趣，而且你只需要40分钟，如果你……你知道，有些疗法
techniques you're scratching the surface after a year so it's it's quick no i haven't heard of that it's interesting well i really appreciate you you sitting down and my daughter is in preschool But we talked about what we're gonna do the next day every day And so she wanted to record a message for you if I could play her saying hey It's before we hop off. I told her that I would and she She's she's five, but she likes. Hi Andy Savage. I'm in the chaos dimension. I have some Halloween decorations up right now
技术，一年后你才触及表面，所以它很快。不，我没听说过那个，这很有趣。嗯，我真的很感谢你坐下来。我女儿在上学前班，但我们每天都会谈论第二天要做什么。所以她想为你录一段信息，如果我可以播放她说的“嘿”。在我们结束之前。我告诉她我会的，她……她五岁，但她喜欢。“嗨，Andy Savage。我在混沌维度。我现在挂了一些万圣节装饰品，
and my baby brother's doing good. It's so sweet and cool that we occupied the same dimension. What's her name? Violet. Hi Violet. Thank you very much for the message. Yeah, she's like very into Sonic the Hedgehog so there's like Chaos Emer like very into Sonic the Hedgehog so
我弟弟表现得很好。我们占据同一个维度真是太甜蜜和酷了。”她叫什么名字？Violet。嗨，Violet。非常感谢你的信息。是的，她非常喜欢《刺猬索尼克》，所以有像“混沌翡翠”（Chaos Emeralds）和《刺猬索尼克》，当那首歌触动她时，她一直要求听。你可以告诉她，我以前也相当喜欢那个电子游戏。嗯，非常感谢，我再次非常感谢。我们要非常感谢 A Savage 坐下来谈论他的艺术作品，嗯，音频和视觉艺术作品都很棒，你应该看看他的网站，他们最近的专辑《Sympathy for Life》可以购买，非常出色。Violet 最喜欢的是《Wide Awake》，我最喜欢的是《Light Up Gold》和《Human Performance》，我认为每个人都应该去听听这两张专辑。
there's like Chaos Emeralds and Sonic the Hedgehog and when she that song spoke to her it's requested all the time you can tell her that I used to I used to like that video game quite a lot too well thank you so much I really appreciate it again we want to give a huge thanks to a savage for sitting down and talking about his artwork um both the audio and visual artwork is amazing you should check out his website uh their most recent album sympathy for life is available uh for purchase it's excellent violet's favorite is wide awake and my favorite is Light Up Gold and Human Performance, two of the albums that I think everyone should check out.
所以非常感谢你的收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
So thank you so much for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢您的收听。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。